matthew mcconaughey took home the oscar
over leonardo dicaprio in 2014 but
willis friend and wolf of Wall Street
co-star take on the statue on Sunday
night have you talked to him have you
offered him any advice do you think he's
going to pull it out on Sunday I haven't
talked to him I don't think he needs any
advice he had a wonderful performance
and you know there's really nothing he
could do now right just hope and pray
you Sunday night and it'll be able Oh
Matthew was honored at varieties third
annual unite for Humanity event on
thursday for his work with his
foundation just keep living I read a
stat today you guys have helped over
10,000 at-risk youth we have ten
thousand alumni so we have 10,000 young
men and women who've gone through our
program in or out now a lot of them
still come back to help out they learn
exercise and nutrition goals it's not a
free ride so they're up at four-thirty
packing up meals to give to needy
families on the holidays they're up at
four-thirty to take a bus trip to go
clean up a beach when I was their age I
don't know if I would have given that
much I wouldn't have given my Saturday
but I'm amazed one hundred percent of
the kids do